- Hi everyone Sal, here from Khan Academy,
welcome to our Homeroom live stream,
very excited about the conversation
we're about to have with Lester Holt.
Before we jump into that conversation,
I will make a few of my
standard announcements one,
just a reminder to folks that Khan Academy
is an out-for-profit if
you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation that can be
done at khan academy.org/donate.
Also wanna give special thanks
to several organizations
that have stepped up over
the last couple of months
when they saw that we were
already running into deficit
pre COVID and that the
deficit only grew as we saw
300% of the traffic we normally
see as all of the folks
are leaning on us for as we figure out
distance learning together.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T and Fastly, Novartis and
the Amgen family foundation,
Amgen Foundation, not
the family foundation.
I also wanna announce, I
announced this on a previous
live stream that we're
taking select versions
of this live stream and
turning them into a podcast.
So if you want to watch, or
maybe you shouldn't be watching,
if you wanna listen to this,
maybe while you're in the car
or some other place we're taking a subset
of our conversations, editing
them a little bit for podcast
and making them available
so you can anywhere you,
you can get your podcast
hopefully you'll see
the Homeroom with Sal shortly.
So with that, I'm really
excited and honored to introduce
someone that you're probably
already familiar with,
someone who you've probably
already seen in your home,
a Lester Holt, anchor
of the NBC Nightly News
with Lester Holt, Lester,
thanks so much for joining us.
- Happy to join you Sal and
yes, people watch me at home
and it's basically from my
home to their home these days.
- Yeah, I think there's
something nice about that.
I know it's above my pay grade,
but you might wanna continue this,
It's very intimate in a nice way.
- Well, it's a lot more
responsibility than I'm used to
normally I go into a big
studio and I don't think
about cameras and sound and
lighting and all that stuff
now I do, and now my big
fear is tripping over a plug,
which has been done and
frightening our signal out of here
but, it's, I always tell
people that as a international
loose organization, we're
used to taking the broadcast
on the road to far-flung
corners of the world
in hospitable places so in many ways,
this wasn't a huge challenge
for us but in a sustaining way
to do our broadcast like this has been
it's been interesting and I
certainly miss the face to face
collaboration with my colleagues.
- I could imagine. I mean you're doing it
at a much higher stakes before I even do
this live stream, I go
through my house yelling,
get off of live stream,
get off of Netflix,
I'm about to get (laughs),
get off of zoom everybody.
(laughs)
So I can have all the...
- I have a dog that occasionally
piped in and then last week
I was watching my grandsons
and the one-year-old,
I'm on the phone he runs into
my little makeshift studio
and of all the things he
touches it's the button
that could knock me off the air.
And I look on the screen and it says,
do you really wish to disconnect?
I'm like, no(laughs)
so it's...(indistinct)
everyone's going through it on some level.
- No, it's really interesting
and so, so there's a bunch
of stuff I'm excited to talk
to you about and I do wanna
encourage anyone watching
on Facebook or YouTube
or social media generally every
now and then this shows up
in other places I didn't expect.
Put questions and we have
team members who are gonna
surface the questions
for Lester and myself
if it's relevant and maybe
a good place to start,
which I think is really
exciting 'cause we have a lot
of young people watching
this and a lot of parents
who watch this is, not
only are you the anchor
of the NBC Nightly News,
you're also the anchor
of the NBC Nightly News Kids Edition,
which is available online
if someone were to search
that look it up, which I
love I've actually watched
many many episodes of it.
Tell us why, why you did
this and what, what this is.
- Well, this was early on
in the pandemic and things
were going south very quickly, we were all
being overwhelmed and I
remember doing the newscast
every night and thinking
there are families watching
this right now and the numbers
and the stories we're telling
are grim and these video diaries
and these healthcare workers
and one of the other producers
on the broadcast said,
"maybe we should do like a
kid show geared toward them."
And we all looked at
each other like of course
that's exactly what we should be doing.
So, it started out very
organic just a handful of folks
kind of scrapping the other
and trying to learn as we go
along about a way to present
some of this very heavy stuff
with this pandemic to
kids in a digestible way.
I mean kids aren't stupid they're watching
what's going on around them,
they're seeing the confusion
and distress among the
adults and we wanted to do
it in bite sizes.
So, we've kept that up and
we've tried to also move
along with the news, so of
course we covered the...
some of the protests and the
Black Lives Matter Movement
and things happening in
space and other things
that might be of interest of
specific interest to kids.
And we like to feature kids to
some of the inspiring things
that they're doing, how they've,
figuring out ways to learn
at home and just kind
of adapt to our reality.
- No and I'll once again and
say, it's really interesting
and I've actually been very
impressed, you take questions
from kids and the questions that they ask
are oftentimes better
than some of what you see
in the experts(laughs) asking
on, on the adult on, on,
on, on television, generally
I think one of the really
interesting things that a lot
of folks wonder and I used
to wonder this when I would
see a Lester Holt on TV,
how did you become Lester Holt?
How do you, how do you
become kind of this trusted
go to person for a whole
country or for the world,
did you think you were going
to do this when you were
a teenager when you were younger or?
There's a question here from
Neupro Mantha on YouTube
what were your struggles you encountered?
A lot of people think
it's I wanted to do it
and then it just happened all of a sudden.
I'd love to hear a little
bit about your journey.
- Things just unfolded for me,
I did wanna be in broadcasting
from a very early age
I had an older brother
eight years older than me
who had a brief stint in
radio and he took me down
to the radio station one day and I thought
this is very very cool and so
that's what I really wanted
to do was radio and be
a DJ at the age of 17
during my senior year in high school,
I got a job at a country
in Western radio station
in Sacramento, California,
midnight to six on Saturdays
and Sundays playing records and
reading the news every hour.
At the same time I was got an internship,
wasn't even a real
internship 'cause I was still
in high school but I managed
to kind of talk my way
in to the NBC station in Sacramento,
the TV station, KCR, right
and kind of hung around there
and helped out in the
public affairs department
and just tried to soak
up as much as I could.
Started college, did
two years in the college
and landed a job in San Francisco
at an all news radio
station so I dropped out,
never went back, kids don't do what I do,
don't do what I do but life
kind of worked out did radio,
went to New York when I was
22, maybe no yeah about 22
and landed a job at the CVS
TV station here then stayed
with CVS, went to Los
Angeles and back to New York
then Chicago, all in local
news and then came to MSNBC
in 2000, and it was the
beginning of this incredible
five year period of news.
I got there, it's just
kind of back to the future
but during the Biden I'm sorry
during the Gore Bush
presidential race and of course
the recount in Florida,
and from that before long
we were staring at 911, the
invasion of Afghanistan,
the invasion of Iraq, that
was all in that really
brief period of time, and
I was principal anchor
for a lot of that and
then kind of worked my way
across the river to NBC
news and weekend today,
weekend Nightly News, Dateline
and finally five years ago
landed in this job.
- And then what would you
say I mean that's actually
an incredible journey I the
fact that you were doing
so much even from such a young age
and you kind of knew
this, I am curious what
and this is sometimes
hard for people to answer
'cause they don't wanna seem
they wanna be modest about it,
but please don't be modest.
What would you think allowed
you to kind of stand out
and eventually, essentially
have the top job
in broadcasting, at least
from my vantage point?
- I played the long game and I
just took it a step at a time
and really never believed
in it could be like
this like overnight success
with that kind of paying your dues.
And a lot of people I worked with talked
about the importance of paying your dues
and learning your craft
and just listening.
I was blessed with good
mentors, people that gave me
sage advice and who admonish
me when I got something wrong
or the script didn't make
any sense or whatever it was
and I just tried to give
everything in each job
and then opportunities
would present themselves.
One guy workforce said,
"you've gotta be ready when
doors open because doors open
at times you don't expect
circumstances you don't expect
but you gotta be ready
to walk through them."
And that's kind of what my
philosophy has always been,
I've always said to people
before I got this job,
I was anchoring three jobs
at NBC news and I said,
"sometimes we're so busy
climbing the ladder that we fail
to like stop and pause on a
wrong and kind of look out
and enjoy the view."
And, I was in place that
wasn't necessarily the top
of the game but for me
I was really enjoying
what I was doing and so when
the opportunity came to anchor
at Nightly News, I was prepared
to walk through that door.
But at the same time I
was perfectly happy doing
what I was doing before.
I love covering news, I love
taking my personal curiosity
and making that my profession
and I just every move
has been I've been tickled by it,
it's been hey, this is great,
it's a new opportunity,
and a new chance.
But I try to think of that
if that's the last job I had,
it's a great job.
- And what do you think when
you look at other people?
Young people especially who
are coming through the ranks
maybe 20 or 30 years before an
earlier version of yourself.
Where do you do you sometimes
look at people like okay
that young one is gonna make
something out of themselves
because of X, Y, and Z and that
person's probably not doing
it the right way.
- Yeah I do see there's I
mean when I whenever I meet
someone who says I'm gonna
be an anchor I'm like
what you wanna be is
you wanna be a reporter
another mentor I had said,
"being a reporter is the
highest calling of what we do."
And I say that to say
this, that when I'm sitting
on that set every night,
yes it's prestigious,
it's the top of the
game, it pays more money
and a lot of good things about
it but the most rewarding
and interesting and fascinating
moments of my career
have not been sitting at an anchor desk.
They've been out on the
field, with camera crews
and a pen and pad and fighting deadlines
and whatever hurricanes or toxic leaks
whatever the story is.
It was just being there
and covering the story
that's what we do.
I am always gonna be a
reporter first as I said,
being an anchor, it's the big
deal, it's a celebrated job,
very cool to get my name on
the wall and all that stuff
but it's all about, it's all
about the art of reporting.
- Do you still get to do
some of that reporting
is that part of your deal that
you'll be able to maybe do
some travel or do some
investigative type reporting?
- I do, I am one of the hallmarks
of this show is we take it
on the road a lot for big
stories, be it a natural disaster
or terrorists or attacks
or big big stories.
It's been difficult for us to
do that during the pandemic,
traveling and and
quarantines and things of...
make things different.
I did travel though to Minneapolis during
the George Floyd story,
we then traveled to Texas
for the funeral there.
So we've gotten out some
but we're still making
the adjustments but yeah
I still like to get out
and tell stories and I still
work for Dateline, I'm sorry
I just hit the camera, I
still do Dateline projects,
I'm working on one right now.
So, that's what I love
to do and like all of us
we're kind of figuring
out what's possible,
how do we adjust, how
we work in this pandemic
but we're we're figuring it out.
- And there's an interesting
question it's kind of related
to that from Facebook Ellen H Omen.
And, I guess the context
for this is, the news
when you watch the news, you
learn about if God forbid
a plane goes down or something
bad happens or death counts
from the pandemic that
tends to be oftentimes
like the leading news.
But the question from Ellen is,
can we have some good news shows too,
wouldn't that be amazing?
Is there a kind of a movement
maybe to try to surface
you're not just the seven
really bad things that happened
in the world but maybe
get people in a good mood
and I say that actually my
mom, I think is addicted
to the news and sometimes it
gets to (laughs) her I think.
- No alright listen, I
tell people all the time
they look at me really I
say there are days that I do
the newscasts and I walk out of the studio
wow that was tough, like
nobody lived in that broadcast
there we can't obviously
dictate I mean some days
are just super heavy but
what we can do is try
and have an arc of
stories in the broadcast
and that's what we aim to do so yes,
there will be whatever the
top story is, there may be
then stories are dealing with
particular issues going on,
but we always like to end
the broadcast on something
uplifting some story we
have different franchises,
inspiring America is one of
them and stories where people
are going above and beyond,
they are taking on an issue
by themselves, they are reaching
out to their fellow man.
And we, I've had people stop
me and ask about that thing,
"I love those stories at the end."
And sometimes I see you tears in your eyes
and yeah that happens,
I'm a big crier sometimes,
but I think it's really
important that we find ways
as often as we can again
we can't always dictate
what the news day will bring but find ways
to kinda center people on
the good that we all share
that we hear so much about the
divisiveness in this country
and it is real but there's
also just a lot of people
who aren't asking what
your political stripes are
and they just wanna help,
and they just wanna make
a difference in this world
and it's part of our job
to recognize them.
- Yeah no, it makes a lot
of sense that I mean related
to that I mean this is a
really interesting question
from Facebook Fay Marie,
how do you keep up with what's important
yet not get overwhelmed by
the volume of news out there?
- Okay, I'm just gonna tell
is it Fay, is that the person?
- Fay.
- Okay Fay, sometimes I don't watch.
And(giggles) I say, I
couldn't say that but then I
during the when we were first
going through the beginning
of this pandemic, I would have
friends say things like that.
That I can't handle it, and
you start to worry about people
seriously about people's
ability to deal with this,
and I would say sometimes you
just gotta walk away from it.
You've gotta turn off the TV
and that's the last message
I know you would wanna
hear from me and I hope
you'll watch me and
then turn it off later.
But what I mean by I don't
mean to be flippant but I think
you do have to give yourself
a breather and sometimes
take it in small doses.
We've been through some
really difficult times
we've been put in the pandemic,
the protests in the streets,
struggling the Black
Lives Matter Movement,
these are all important things
that we're struggling with
in different ways.
You've got the politics
firing at us right now,
you need to be informed,
you can't totally unplug
but take breaks, give
yourself a moment and try
and digest these things.
It's helpful to me, believe
it or not there's sometimes
during the day when I'm working, of course
I have to be plugged in,
but there are some weekends
where I have to say you know
I'm gonna take the morning off.
Now, I have my phone, if something
big happens, I can watch,
I get this text alerts
still, I know what's going on
in the news, but I do
give myself breathers
and I think it could be healthy.
- Yeah. I couldn't agree
more and I think if anything
it can give you more perspective
if you have a breather
you can digest it and think
about it more as a historian
than someone just caught up in the moment.
So, it makes a ton of sense.
There's another question I
think from people hearing your,
I think pretty impressive
narrative especially in how much
motivation and how common
agents you exercised
when you were young this is from YouTube
Wakrina M says, you found
your passion pretty early,
what advice do you give for
kids regarding passionate
careers, what should they
look for, how do they know?
- I think I had several passions.
Music is one of my other
passions, am a bass player,
and I used to play in
a band I say used to,
we're not able to get together
anymore, but I was blessed
to be raised by two wonderful
parents who basically
instilled this idea
that we can do anything
and that you don't have
to take no for an answer
and that you can live your dreams,
and they were very supportive
of me and so I never really
questioned whether I could do
anything and then I don't say
that from a point of arrogance,
but it was a sense of
if I apply myself if this
is really what I wanna do,
then I can do it.
And then, I would spend
so much time studying,
I wanted to be on the radio
so I would sit this is
sounds a little pathetic now
but as a 15, 16 year old,
I sit in my bedroom with
well, a record player,
a tape recorder and a
microphone and a newspaper
and I would play radio(clears throat).
I would talk up a record,
I'd give the weather,
Sacramento weather it's
gonna be high of 75 today
at a low of 55, we've got
more coming up but first
we got a song from whoever it
was and I would do the whole
DJ thing and then I would go like okay,
let's take a news break right now
and I would give the headlines.
I would this is terrible, I
used to take its unsanitary now,
but I would take pencils
and pens to put up my mouth
and work on my diction
and then in high school,
I got a chance to do the
morning announcements every day,
I was the guy that would it
was the corner of a lancer,
so good morning lancers, It's 8.30
and here's what's happening,
the Spanish Columbus meeting
in room E2 after school today,
soccer has been canceled,
whatever I would do that
whole thing and then I would
'cause I was in this
whole DJ mode I would try
and do it like a real radio newscast.
And so it would always end
and that's what's happening
it's 8.38 and your up to date.
(chuckles)
And that was my thing so... (indistinct)
what a total nerd I was, my goodness.
(laughs)
- What did your friends,
did your friends give you?
Were your friends like
yeah, I know that guy
or did they give you a hard time?
'Cause they thought hey,
this guy is sounding like a real DJ.
- No, I think people got into it.
I mean at least they told me they got it
but I don't know maybe they
were talking behind my back
but it's a long question
but the idea was man
I this was what I wanted to do and I knew
I was gonna have to figure it out and so,
I got books and I listened
and to radio stations,
I would, I remember coming
out of Los Angeles big market
with my tape recorder
and recording all the big
radio stations there and
then taking them back
and studying them.
It was really how I kind
of lived out this fashion.
- Wow, no I think that's
a huge takeaway for kids
I mean, anyone any young
person listening is just
get deep in whatever you're trying to do.
And I guess(indistinct)
find something else but yeah
that's I mean that's
a wonderful... people.
A lot of people are asking
you about your bass playing
I mean, do you still play bass?
And I mean, do you literally
like show up at gigs
and like on bass it's
Lester Holt also anchor
of the Nightly News?
- Well, as i said it was another passion.
And so I wanted to, I was
listening to a band when I...
and suddenly the bass stood
out to me and I thought
I love that sound and I
decided I wanted to play bass
and once again this Mr. Obsessive here,
I saved up some money
from delivering papers
and I went to a pawn shop
in downtown Sacramento,
I bought this cheap base
and a couple of books
and went on and taught myself the bass
and started playing in
the junior high jazz band
and jazz choir and then
I did that in high school
and a part of college as well.
So I play, I play electric bass
and I play the big upright bass as well.
I did J I had a friend
that used to do gigs
and here in Manhattan, he'd
asked me to come sometimes
and join him sit in on a set
and back them up on base,
and sometimes it was very fun
because they would announce
the group during the break
and they'd say had on bass
Lester Holt, you could see
people in the audience go,
oh my God, that is him not
expecting to see me there.
And then a couple of years
ago, we formed a band at NPC,
we call ourselves The Rough
Cuts because most of the members
are video editors from Dateline NBC,
but we're all NBC folks and
we would sneak out on Monday
or Tuesday mornings go to a
studio in Midtown Manhattan
and rehearse and we would
do gigs here in town from
time to time, and we're all
kind of in this depression,
'cause we obviously can't
meet and play right now
but I always say, so TV news
is my passion right now.
I always say it's important
to have something else
in your life though,
because I never wanna be,
I never want this to define me
that oh he is the anchorman,
It's what I do, but I'm also the musician
and there's other facets of my
life so I think it's healthy
for all of us to discover
something else in our lives
so we're not pigeonholed and
in some other role necessarily,
not that I mind being the anchor.
(chuckles)
- And what type of music do you all play?
- Our band plays mostly
pop and rock covers.
Funny thing is jazz is kinda
my main thing, jazz and pop.
So, I was never a big rocker.
So, when I got together
with this group they started
throwing out these songs and
fortunately I have a really
good ear and I can pick
things up pretty quickly
but a lot of them I'd never
heard of, we're playing songs
I never heard of and I come
home and tell my wife say yeah
we're doing this song and I
said, it's pretty good she goes
"yeah, yeah as many discovered
back in 1979 or whatever."
(laughs)
So, I would say how we grew
up as kind of helped me
embrace my inner rocker but
it's been a lot, a lot of fun.
- No I can only imagine.
So folks who are regular
viewers know that I used to be
an abandoned high school but I
suspect I was not as talented
as you are.
I was the lead singer and
singing is a very generous term
for what I did.
(laughs)
It yeah it was heavy metal,
now I'm much more calm,
I'd do more like folksy,
acoustic type stuff.
One question and there's
a couple of questions
on this dimension and I'm
curious 'cause it seems
like the media generally
has evolved over the last
several decades, there was
kind of the Walter Cronkite
era back in the day.
Do you see that it has evolved,
do you see that the media
is kind of the fourth
estate as kind of holding
government accountable,
making sure that our democracy
is informed with the
polarization and sometimes people
kind of be able to pick
and choose what they get?
Where do you see where
we are in that narrative
for the role of media?
- Well, I think our role
is still the same obviously
to especially at the
network level to kind of
be the newscast of record every
night to kind of tell you,
what's happening in the
world and get you focused.
At the same time, I recognize
and understand our influence
isn't what it was when I was
a boy and watching the evening
programs, people have choices now,
they have other distractions,
they have other ways to get their news.
I recognized by the time
they sit down with us
at 6.30 eastern time
that they generally know
the big stories of the day,
they know there's something
going on with whether the
post office can handle ballots
and they know some horrible
new Corona numbers came out.
As a friend of mine told me he says,
"I want you not to get the news."
He says, "I want you to
get your take on the news."
My take being our take is a broadcast,
the stories that we choose
to cover, how we cover them,
the perspective we try to
offer and the to help people
really understand the
importance of these things.
So on that level I think
we're still vital but again,
it's not that idea of the
whole world has to kind of stop
at this time.
That said many a TV writer
has tried to write off
the future of the
network evening programs,
but at the end of the day
there's still 20 million
or plus people who are watching
every night and I think
we've all seen big increases
in interest right now during
this particular trying
time in the country,
people are craving facts and information.
We did take I mean, let's
be honest we did take some
cheap shots from on
high about our business
and the integrity of journalists
journalism in this country
but I think we have risen above that.
I think that people
recognize that they need
these broadcasts to
really deliver the facts
and to help understand and
sort out really really noisy
environment out there of
information that's flying
at you from all different
directions some true, some not.
- No, absolutely and I do think
that the kind of the evening
broadcast news is kind
of the still the go to if
when you really can't sense
the bias that you can...
and some other things that
you can get either on cable
or in the internet generally
just maybe one last question
we're obviously an
interesting times, you are,
it's your job to be the
observer and the commentator
on that for our country, for the world,
how are you thinking about
the times where and what
do you think folks are gonna say
in 10 years about this time?
- Yeah, I had the conversations
just few days ago I said,
when the history of this
pandemic is written,
they're gonna spend a lot
of time talking about how we
managed to find even
that a way to divide us
over simple things like
wearing a face covering,
maintaining the ability to maintain some
physical distance between people.
I wouldn't have thought
those would be the,
those would be issues we'd
be struggling especially
even with being tainted politically,
I think that has surprised
me but it'll be part
of the history of how this has written.
I think also we'll talk
about misinformation
and how dangerous it is
to democracy in general
but certainly on an issue
that is so life and death.
And I say that with that
hyperbole, I mean it is,
it's truly a life and death
matter and facts matter
and words matter and balance matter.
And, so I think that's gonna
be part of how these times
will be described.
I was maybe a little pollyannish,
I thought when this pandemic broke out,
I thought this would be one
that we would see the country
really come together
and we have a large for,
I don't wanna discount that
but I think I didn't see
this as being as divisive
as it has turned out
but it's part of the story
we'll continue to cover it.
We as one of the franchises
we do facts over fear,
that's one of our guiding
principles of how we covered
the pandemic and we will march forward.
- No, that's super helpful
really good context.
Well well Lester, thank
you so much once again
I'm self conscious this whole
time that I'm so homebrew
(laughs)
compared to what you do,
but this is a real treat
and a real honor to be able
to talk to you about all
of these things.
- Well also I've been
impressed by what you do
for a very long time and
I appreciate the interest,
always fun to come on and
talk about what we do,
we're very proud of our operation
and love to show it off at folks.
- Right, now thank you so much Lester.
- Alright. Cheers.
- Well, thanks everyone
for joining again hopefully
you enjoyed that as much as I did,
I am curious Lester didn't
mention which pop songs he plays.
I, maybe I'll do some
followup I am curious
and there's, it looks like
there's some requests too,
for people to hear me
saying maybe at some point
although I won't sing the
songs I sang in high school.
I'll do something much more
gentle but hopefully you enjoyed
today's live stream and
I look forward to seeing
you all next week where we're,
we promised to have a whole
bunch of more interesting
guests, just like what we saw this week.
Thanks everyone. Have a good weekend.
(ring)